straight ahead on lawn crime daily
britney spears's father will remain a
co-conservator for now
a judge denying the pop icons request
one week after her emotional plea
why jamie spears is now calling for an
investigation this to me seems
more like has all the feel of crisis
management
and bill cosby is now a free man what
the disgraced comedian has to say
about his conviction being thrown out
plus former president trump's company
and one of his longtime executives
pleading not guilty to tax crime charges
and a nexum sex cult survivor is
speaking out about why she blew the
whistle on leader keith renery and his
accomplice
actor allison mack she's a monster very
sociopath
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
we begin with developments in britney
spears conservatorship case
as her father requests an investigation
into his daughter's claims
she's been abused law and crimes angela
levy is here with what
with that and more news from the court
brian the judge in this case formalized
a decision to make jamie spears the
co-conservator of his daughter's estate
as spears requested an investigation
into those disturbing allegations made
by his daughter
[Applause]
a week after britney spears fans
gathered outside the courthouse to
listen to her speak about the
conservatorship
her father jamie is asking the court for
an investigation i think he's been
taking a lot of grief in the media
in new court documents jamie spears
attorneys say they want to determine the
veracity of the allegations and claims
made by britney spears
and to determine what corrective actions
if any need to be
taken california attorney mark garrigus
who represented scott peterson
has been watching the conservatorship
case closely
and has thoughts on the request for a
hearing if your number one concern
is your daughter there are other ways to
do this or handle this other than an
evidentiary hearing an evidentiary
hearing
is to do what is to make more of a
spectacle out of this
to to try to redeem yourself or
something like that it's not about you
it's about her
in another filing jamie spears casts any
blame for his daughter's care on jody
montgomery
the conservator of britney spears person
jamie spears attorneys write
that he hasn't served in that role since
2019
and montgomery has been in charge of
britney spears day-to-day personal care
and medical treatment
i think the judge has got little or no
choice but to have a hearing
i think this judge is going to do the
right thing i think the right thing here
is to
dial this back and relax some of these
things and
maybe appoint somebody else uh and uh
and try to refashion this in a way that
is healthy or moves towards a healthy
spot
now jamie spears is the co-conservator
of his daughter's estate meaning
he manages the money along with a trust
company
he is asking the court to require
britney spears to appear
in the courtroom on july 14th to say
exactly what she wants brian thanks
angenet joining us today is legal
analyst dina dahl and terry austin
dina do you find it odd that jamie
spears neither denies or confirms
britney spears allegations he just wants
a hearing
i mean i imagine at this point anything
he says is based on what his lawyer
is advising him because he is acting in
a
legal capacity here as a conservator and
as we heard from
britney spears she may want to sue him
she thinks there could be criminal
issues so
i imagine they're telling him not really
to say much we did hear a statement from
miss montgomery herself she said that
there is no restriction
for britney spears to get married or to
have children
with her conservatorship so it's also
possible the father thought that
miss montgomery was addressing some of
those specific issues
right so maybe some legal issues there
not to talk too much or maybe just
playing close to the vest
uh terry could this hearing have britney
on the stand telling all
i think she might she certainly is going
to give more information
than we've heard from before last week
she spoke for 24 minutes brian and it
did not seem to move
judge penny at all her decision is still
as it has been
keeping the conservatorship there i
think 13 years is a very long time
and we know that she has not in
any way shape or form shown any outward
signs of depression or mental illness
and she still is not allowed to manage
her personal or
financial issues so i think and i've
said this before that there's something
inherently wrong with the
conservatorship system when someone who
seems so much in control of her life
isn't able to maintain that control
herself yeah the judge seems to be
punting the issue hopefully
we're at a point where it can be
resolved and jeanette what does jody
montgomery have to say
about this well brian i reached out to
her representatives her lawyers and they
sent this two-page statement back to be
in which jodi montgomery and her lawyers
say that they've been acting
in britney spears best interest while
attending to her medical needs her
personal care needs
during this whole time since they've
been in charge of her person
since 2019 they said that her ability to
get married as dina mentioned and have
children is not affected by this
conservatorship
and the statement ends by saying that
she's looking forward jodie montgomery
is to
helping britney spears get on a path
where she doesn't need to
have somebody like her in charge of her
personal affairs any longer
yeah and that's the ultimate goal here
hopefully this hearing
brings us to a point where we can have
an end of this conservatorship
but also a healthy britney spears who
can resolve and take care of her own
financial and personal issues thank you
everyone turning now to other top legal
news making headlines
actor james franco agrees to pay 2.2
million dollars to settle a sexual
misconduct lawsuit
the settlement would close a
class-action lawsuit brought by two of
the actors former students filed
in 2019. franco founded his own acting
and filming school in 2014
where allegedly he would push his
students into filming scenes
they found to be increasingly
inappropriate and sexually exploited
frank was widely known for his
award-winning role in the disaster
artist
the lawsuit names franco's production
company and partners as co-defendants
franco would not have to admit
wrongdoing the settlement includes
non-economic terms that have not been
made public
and in new york so-called soho karen
pleaded not guilty to new felony hate
crime charges
police say 23-year-old mia poncero
falsely accused a black teen
of stealing her phone last december in a
video that has since gone viral she's
seen demanding the phone back and
tackling the team
poncetto is facing two charges of
unlawful imprisonment which now contain
a hate crime enhancement
after court attorneys for pancetto
accused prosecutors of overreaching
calling the charges shameful
still ahead on law and crime daily the
trump organization
and one of its officers facing a judge
over tax fraud allegations
but first a look at bill cosby now out
of prison
we break down why the pennsylvania
supreme court overturned his conviction
next
[Music]
welcome back reaction is pouring in
after the pennsylvania supreme court
overturned the conviction of bill cosby
the disgraced comedian is now
at home after spending nearly three
years behind bars
cosby was seen in front of his house on
wednesday joined by his appellant
attorney and spokesperson the
pennsylvania supreme court vacated the
disgraced comedian's conviction
ruling prosecutors violated his
constitutional rights the comedian took
to social media writing
i have never changed my stance nor my
story i have always maintained my
innocence
cosby was sentenced to three to ten
years in prison for drugging and
sexually assaulting temple university
employee
andrea constant in 2005 cosby reached a
non-prosecutorial agreement with
then-philadelphia district attorney
bruce castor castro is now known for
representing former president donald
trump
at the impeachment proceedings a new
prosecutor brought criminal charges
against cosby
in 2015 and he was convicted after a
second trial
the commonwealth's highest court ruled
cosby should have never been prosecuted
because of the deal attorney gloria
allred represents many of cosby's
accusers
and says the decision was devastating
for them they were
very brave and despite the
pennsylvania supreme court's decision i
want everyone to know that i do believe
that this was a very
important fight for justice while this
decision says cosby cannot be retried
allred still is pursuing a civil lawsuit
by judith huff against cosby in
california
in that case our client alleges in the
lawsuit
that she was the victim of
child sexual abuse by mr cosby at the
playboy mansion in southern california
that case was stayed while cosby's
appeal in pennsylvania was spending
allred says she plans to be back in
court for it to resume in august
back with us as legal analyst dina dahl
and terry austin
terry a technicality technicality sorry
exonerated not guilty a violation of
constitutional rights
people are calling this so many
different things what do you call it
well brian it's not a technicality but
it is a procedural decision
involving a substantive constitutional
issue no question about it
the pennsylvania supreme court vacated
the conviction
because cosby was denied due process and
he was denied due process because he was
promised
if he testified at this deposition that
it would not be used against him
and it was used against him so i think
the court made the right decision
but i think they got the remedy wrong
the remedy here
really should have been that the case
could be
retried just not using the evidence that
they
gathered from that deposition the way
the court decided it says they can never
retry this case
and that would really be giving any
prosecutor
the power to pardon people forever and i
don't think that's what's
really intended yeah you brought up the
prosecutor former
prosecutor uh caster had given that
offer of a
non-prosecutor agreement and then wasn't
able to actually give it
and so dina maybe it's the public
defender in me but why isn't there more
blame being put on
caster for this fault of incorrectly
extending that offer
and why are so many people looking at
cosby instead
well it's interesting because in some
ways his offer
did have value because the victim there
was able to then bring a civil suit
and phil cosby was no longer able to
invoke the fifth amendment because they
didn't have
criminal charges hanging over him with
in connection with it
so he had to testify for four days
and that civil lawsuit resulted in a 3.3
million dollar judgment
so it without him giving that offer
saying he wasn't going to have
criminal charges off the table he would
have been able to invoke the fifth
amendment she wouldn't have gotten that
civil damages most likely so you could
argue that
the intended result of that prosecutor
was effective his intention was that
he should recover in a civil court
because he didn't think he could make
charges sick
and a criminal court makes sense it
seemed like he tried to choose his
battles the civil over the criminal
the second prosecutor tried to get that
criminal as well but of course as we see
the pennsylvania supreme court
overturned that decision
thanks for that insight both of you now
let's check in on the live trials of the
law and crime network
first with california versus robert
durst
the wealthy real estate air is on trial
for the murder of his best friend
susan berman before this durst was tried
for the murder of his neighbor maurice
black
whose dismembered remains were found in
galveston bay
juris admitted to the dismemberment but
claimed self-defense in the killing and
was later acquitted
in court attorneys are now reading
transcribed testimonies from the morris
black trial
including the medical examiner who
confirmed that black was dead
12 hours before being dismembered now to
colorado and the trial of mark redwine a
retired wildlife expert testified it's
highly unlikely an animal attacked and
killed
dylan redwine in 2012. that's been one
of the main arguments from the defense
dylan's remains were found in different
locations off middle mountain road
his skull was found two years after his
other remains the prosecution says dylan
died from blunt force trauma to the
skull
caused by mark redwine make sure to
check out the law and crime network for
gavel to gather coverage of both of
those trials
coming up on crime daily harsh words
from a judge sentencing smallville
actress alison mack
for her role with the nexium sex cult
plus former president donald trump's
reaction to newly unsealed charges
against his company and top executive
the 15 count indictment explained
[Music]
ahead
welcome back prosecutors unsealed a
15-count indictment against the company
of the former president and
its chief financial officer they're
pleading not guilty to all
accusations alan weisenberg and trump
organization pleaded not guilty to
allegations
of a 15-year scheme to defraud
prosecutors allege that from march 2005
to june 2020
the defendants engaged in a manner that
was quote off the books
according to a grand jury indictment
weisselberg evaded taxes and benefited
to the tune
of 1.7 million dollars among the charges
grand larceny in the second degree
criminal tax fraud in the third degree
and falsifying business records in the
first degree
the charges are the first for the
manhattan da's two-year investigation
into the company which fought all the
way to the u.s supreme court
over tax records the former president is
calling the charges a disgrace
and a continuation of the witch hunt
let's bring back legal analyst dina dahl
and co-host terry austin
terry the charges range in terms of
sentencing i know the grand larceny in
the second degree is a
classy felony we can do up to 15 years
do you see this being a trial or maybe
both sides working out a plea deal
brian let's hope it's a plea deal if you
just take
how long it took to get the tax records
it took several years
you can just imagine how long it's going
to take to try this case
not only that but the testimony is going
to be
extremely dry this is all about tax
fraud so you're going to be hearing
records and discussions about entries
into their tax forms
and i think we'd be wasting taxpayer
dollars i think what might happen is we
might see alan weisenberg
we might see him do a plea deal and
cooperate
in exchange for more information about
the trump organization since he knows
so much about the ins and outs of all of
the finances
yeah if there was to be a plea deal they
would have to strike at least the top
two maybe three counts
because some of those charges are
mandatory jail time we'll see how that
plays out though
dina is this it for a two-year
investigation
or do you see this as being the first
indictment of many
well prosecutors certainly hope that
this is the first of many and
it will most likely depend on whether
not mr reifelberg cooperates
it's possible that they're looking into
manipulation of property values and bank
fraud charges
but the one charge that everybody is
looking for is michael cohen said that
mr whitehillberg
was the one who was able to kind of hide
the stormy daniels hush payment villa
that payment would be a campaign
violation
charge against mr trump himself
did that occur will we ever find out
only probably if mr wesley cooperates
well time will tell we'll see how that
plays out thank you
when we come back we sit down with one
of the nexum whistleblowers
her reaction to actor allison mack's
three-year sentence for the former sex
cult participation
after the break
welcome back one of the victims and a
whistleblower of the nexium sex cult is
speaking out after
allison mack was sentenced to prison our
adam classville was there as the judge
handed down
strong words to the former smallville
actor
alison mack was just sentenced to three
years in prison
far below the federal sentencing
guidelines there were questions about
whether she would get anywhere from 14
to 17 years the judge went far below
that at an emotional 90-minute hearing
where
two victims spoke one of them called
alison mack the smallville actress and
keith reniere
the most evil monsters she ever met
honestly her eyes looked dead it was
very much like that feeling of a
sociopath where she was actually
able to receive what i was saying
the government recommended that she
would get a lighter sentence because of
her cooperation
right before the trial she shared
evidence about the secret sisterhood the
organization
das within the nixiam cult that
led to the conviction of keith ranieri
the judge found that she was both in the
words of
das both a master and a slave that she
was said to be by the judge both a
perpetrator and something of a victim
herself
which made for part of the difficulty
according to judge gareth in sentencing
hurt
i sat down with jessica jones earlier
today and she says alison mack actually
mailed her a letter apologizing before
the sentencing
i didn't feel much and i'm a deeply
empathetic highly sensitive person
and it was a lot of buzzwords it was a
lot of
fluffy generalizations there was no real
indication that she had any sense of
a pinkie's worth of what i went through
just like
i can't imagine what you went through i
know you can't imagine what i went
through
on top of that you know
and i'm so sorry isn't gonna cut it
and and also when she's just blaming
keith keith made me do this it was his
teachings no
that is not that i've seen her i've
witnessed her i've felt her
that that is you we all have a choice in
life and yes can people be brainwashed
can be people be coerced to do things
that they maybe wouldn't normally do
a hundred percent but she was a leader
at the helm there was something she got
off in doing this there was something
that
the sense of power over these women
that she loved that was her own thing
keith just
helped her cultivate that
dina three years where it could have
been 14 to 17 does that seem like just a
slap on the wrist
for mac based on what she was accused of
i mean it's very low but the reason why
it is is because the prosecutor
did ask for leniency she gave a
recording
of that ceremony where the initials of
rainier was
put on the women i imagine that was very
crucial and persuasive evidence
at a trial to see this video so she did
help him
get the radio such a high sentence was
120 years
this reminds me of the fact that i like
to say often
is that the legal system is inadequate
in remedy and this is an example of that
the harm that was done to these
women certainly three years is not going
to remedy that
situation but from a legal standpoint it
made sense
because she cooperated and helped put
him away for a longer period of time
now terry what do you make of the
judge's words at sentencing especially
when you just heard jessica's words
about how
alison mack was reacting in terms of
that letter that was sent to her
you know it's interesting the judge
completely sided with the prosecution as
dina was just mentioning
and the fact that we got this
substantial assistance
i think really did influence the judge
and and influenced what the judge had to
say
the other issue is i do think that we
had an apology here
she was a victim herself she pled guilty
so she didn't waste taxpayer dollars
and at the end of the day we did see
that keith reneer
got the 120 years which is quite a long
sentence so
i really think that we did what we
needed to do here and we got the main
person involved behind bars
absolutely it was it was moving for me
to hear jessica speak
thank you both thank you for joining us
here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you